[Music]
hello and welcome to a bumper 90-minute
edition of trevor phillips on sunday
it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas christmas 2020 that is when we
couldn't get together with our
colleagues at work or friends and family
at home
but not everything's the same the good
tidings are that this year most of the
populations vaccinated and more than 20
million of us are boosted hallelujah
but before you rejoice hark to the choir
of governments scientists and the bma
they want yet more restrictions
including a ban on indoor mixing you
might need a smaller turkey
as for the prime minister in the past
week he lost half his back benches in a
crucial parliamentary vote more than
half his electorate in a by-election and
last night lord frost the minister who
was supposed to deliver the final brexit
deal lord frost didn't get the memo
about when lords are supposed to be
leaping that's after christmas mate
we'll try to unwrap all that with our
guests this morning
in a moment i'll speak to the man with
the huge responsibility of leading the
government's management of kovid and the
health service health secretary sajid
javid
and will be joined by his opposite
number in labor shadow health secretary
wes streeting
we'll try to make sense of the latest
phase of the covet crisis with former
chief scientific advisor to the uk
government sir mark walport
and dive deeper into the data with
statistician and cambridge professor
david spiegelhalter
meanwhile it's been another
extraordinary political week we'll speak
to liberal democrat leader ed davey
following the party's stunning victory
in the north shropshire
and that of course piled yet more
pressure on prime minister boris johnson
which has only increased with the shock
resignation of his key brexit lieutenant
lord frost yesterday so we'll hear from
leading brexiteer tory backbencher peter
bone
the hospitality industry's leading
called for more support from the
chancellor as pubs and restaurants
suffer from cancellations and plunging
sales in a crucial trading period so
we'll speak to the world-renowned chef
and restaurateur michelle rue
given all that it might be easy to
forget it's just a few days to christmas
i'll speak to the bishop of dover rose
hudson wilkin
but let's start i'm joined by health
secretary sajid javed good morning
health secretary good morning um
what do we know this morning about the
spread
of omicron
infections and crucially
hospitalizations
well ever since we've learned about this
variant our strategy has been clear to
to buy time to time to assess it and
time to build our defenses
we're learning more about omicron all
the time but the truth is we still don't
know uh enough and uh that there's a
gaps in the in the data uh that we have
uh there there are significant
uncertainties as we look ahead but we
must work with the data that we've got
and not let the perfect be the enemy of
the good so
let me just share with you very quickly
what we do know and first of all we know
that omicron spreads very very quickly
we can all see the rising case numbers
but we know that there are many more
people behind those case numbers that
are infected because not everyone is is
taking a test or there's always a delay
in the in in getting test results and so
the actual number of infections would be
significantly higher than what case
numbers suggest and we know that case
numbers are and infections are doubling
at around
two to three times every two to three
days and that's observed data here in
the uk from south africa from
netherlands denmark that's observed data
of omicron the second thing we do know
is around vaccines so we know that your
two vaccines are sadly not enough to
protect you against symptomatic disease
but three vaccines are three vaccines
are excellent in the protection they
provide that's why we've focused very
heavily on our booster program in the
last few weeks i'm pleased to say in the
in the last week in england we've seen
four million boosts over four million
boosts we've seen new records being hit
every day i'm told that yesterday was a
new record day uh as well and and so
that that is a a very high level of
protection we can build on but the third
thing that we don't know enough about
and this is important trevor is that so
we know about the spread we know about
the vaccines but we don't know if enough
about the severity of uh omicron and so
there is data from south africa when you
look at their hospitalization rate
versus delta that that that definitely
suggests they got a lower
hospitalization rate but we don't know
whether if if that means the the virus
itself is intrinsically um less severe
or does it mean that south africans have
you know more
more protection through
your natural infection or vaccines or in
other ways so
and just the final point because if i if
i may is that with the severity that
even if it turns out to be less severe
and therefore a smaller percentage of
people are hospitalized here in the uk
than with delta a small percentage of a
large number of infections could still
mean a significant number of
hospitalizations okay that's a good
complete comprehensive picture just one
small detail um the
reported number of infections running
something like 90 000 maybe 100 000 a
day but you've just said that you think
actually that probably means that the
actual level of infections is much
higher we're being told that fracks for
example it could be as high as 300 000
what what is the multiple to which
you're working right now if the official
figure that we're seeing is 90 000 what
do you really think it is well so let's
to be clear about this the
you said reported a number of affections
about 90 thousand not infections that's
case numbers and the difference between
a case and an infection is a is a cases
are a subset of infections that's where
someone was feeling unwell they've got a
test and it's been confirmed so the 90
000 by the way isn't uh just omicron
that is delta still predominantly delta
and with about the
a a significant degree of that being
omicron but infections what we already
know let me
perhaps i can better explain with delta
because we've got much more data on that
typically the case numbers represent
around a fifth or a quarter of total
infections at any one time and so with
omicron we know that the infections that
we sorry the cases that we're getting
the confirmed cases it will be a subset
of uh of total infections but because of
the the speed at which it's growing
doubling every two to three days the the
it's likely to be an even smaller
proportion the cases of total infection
so it's hard to say with any kind of
certainty what's the total number of
infections but we know
from from all this data that they are
growing significantly in the community
so for example
we know from a test called s gene target
failure which is basically a proxy test
for omicron it's a lot quicker doing
that than the sequencing we know that
it's currently running at around 60
percent of all cases
or new cases in england overall okay so
in fact we could see be seeing a level
of omicron infection which is more than
five times the numbers that we case
numbers at work that we are seeing
reported
let me ask you about another specific
issue
what do we know about the proportion of
uh people who are remain unvaccinated
well we know first of all in terms of
numbers uh about 88 percent of the
population over the age of 12 have taken
at least one vaccine and 80 percent have
taken two over half the people of adult
adults are are now boosted so that's
really good in terms of your great set
of numbers especially the boosters the
biggest booster program in europe
there's about let's say around 10 of the
population that remain unvaccinated and
we know in hospital when you look at
hospitalizations they make up a
disproportionate amount of of those that
are severely ill in fact if we look at
those that are the the most ill in
hospital needing the most care and
attention around nine out of ten of them
are unvaccinated if i can say trevor
because it's a really important issue
that
people have had over a year almost a
year now to get vaccinated
there's still 10 percent of our
population that have chosen for whatever
reason not to get vaccinated
adults yeah 5 million plus and
and i just cannot emphasize enough the
impact that they are having on the rest
of society they must really think about
the damage they are doing to society by
they take up hospital beds that could
have been used for someone with maybe a
heart problem or maybe someone who's
waiting for their elective surgery but
instead of protecting themselves and
protecting their community they choose
not to get vaccinated they are really
having a damaging impact and and i just
can't stress enough please do come
forward and get vaccinated
it's a really positive thing to do not
just for yourself for your loved ones
but for your community too i am i've
dwelt at some length on the numbers
because
this is at the heart
of the dispute dispute that's brewing
amongst your parliamentary colleagues
you suggested for example at the
beginning of this week that um we could
be up to 200 000 cases a day infections
infections a day
the trends don't necessarily
as we understand the data suggest that
that's quite where we are
some of your colleagues think that
you're overstating the data in order to
allow you to bring in more restrictions
on the population
well in fact we would the data we use is
the data as it's being uh observed so we
know case numbers we understand a lot
more about covid and and infections over
the last couple of years a lot of the
data has been built up we
globally you know through scientists
around the world they understand a lot
more about that it is true however that
you can't be certain about everything
especially with a new varied we can see
already in the community how quickly
this is growing
but when when analysis is done so for
example the the sage committee of
scientists that advice government have
just published uh what they view as
their as their latest assessment of the
situation that
they've given an analysis and as
ministers of course we will look at that
analysis but we can't just sort of
simply accept it as you know that is the
fact and that is definitely what's going
to happen as ministers we do have to
challenge it we have to
look at some of the underlying
assumptions and and challenge on those
and also as ministers when we make
decisions on the data that we are
presented with of course we have to
think you're broader than than in just
the the epidemiological situation and
have to think about that any any action
that we take the impact that it might
have on
people's life chances on businesses on
children so ministers jobs is
a much broader view but before we get to
that what um your critics would say is
that you get properly presented with a
range of scenarios by your scientific
advisors and what i think many would be
saying is that
you choose the scenario to which you are
responding and invariably that's turning
out to be the most pessimistic so for
example you yourself have just said that
the emerging evidence from south africa
is that this might be
omicron might be less severe it might be
than we might be but you've chosen
to treat to act as though it is at least
as severe as delta so that you
are actually choosing the evidence to
which you're responding rather than
looking at the range of evidence you're
being offered by scientists no trevor
family i don't think that's the case at
all and let me explain is that we it
would be
it would be wrong absolutely wrong for
government to just to say look we think
this is as severe and that's how we're
going to behave because we don't know
there's a lot of uncertainty around
omicron and we have to accept that there
are gaps in the data as i've said but we
have to use the data that we've got the
data that we do have is around how fast
it is growing the data about the
vaccines so health secretary is the data
you asked for graham medley
let me just put this to you okay the
graham medley who's the chairman of the
sage modeling committee told the
spectator yesterday we generally model
what we are asked to model there is a
dialogue in which policy teams discuss
with the modelers what they need to
inform their policy what is that
supposed to mean if it doesn't mean that
they're giving you the evidence that you
want i think what it means is that
they as in this case i think he must be
referring to sage which are the
government's sort of uh scientific
advisors is that what they are modeling
is the question they would have been
asked broadly put is taking into account
all the
the data you have both from the uk and
abroad on this new variant where do you
think it's heading i think that's the
broad question and they inevitably and
perfectly understandably would come up
with a number of assumptions that they
would make but as i've said our job as
ministers then is to obviously to look
at that report it is very sobering when
you look at it but to to look at it and
then to to challenge to sensibly
challenge underlying assumptions but if
the report only tells you what you want
to hear
there's not much challenge involved
there isn't it well it's not it's i mean
he's telling he's saying that we tell
the government the things that it's
asking us for we're not telling them the
things that
other things that we might know but
they're not well asking in the sense i
think what he means is that
asking in the sense that the the the
government's request is tell us what you
think the the data suggests about where
this thing is heading it is you know if
it was something that i was asking for
of course what i'd be asking if if it i
went who would want to ask for an
outcome uh like the one that they're
suddenly currently presenting my job is
to is to challenge that and and that is
what the government is doing and i think
it's the appropriate thing to do you
know there are some people uh
there's some people out there that think
that that lockdown is the answer uh to
any any need well let's come to the face
there are others that think that you
shouldn't do anything at all and my my
job the government's job is actually to
to look at the data to get the best
assessment we possibly can and actually
all right let's come to what you
actually have to do um
you are almost going to have to ask
people to undertake or endure new
restrictions and it's being um
reported that there is a plan are there
plans being drawn up for a circuit
breaker locked down after christmas i'm
not asking you whether you've decided on
that or not though you can tell me but
is it true that those plans are being
drawn up
we've taken measures already i took the
the plan b measures through parliament
this week which i didn't enjoy doing one
bit at all i didn't come into to
government to to restrict freedoms of
people but i think people understand you
know why we we are
presented that action uh to parliament
and and we keep the situation under
review of course we will assess the
report the recent report will be given
by sage we will challenge certain
assumptions and we'll come to a
government decision but but can i say we
are entering uh this phase of this
pandemic in a very strong position and
the reason for that strong position is
because we opened up in the summer we
have the best vaccination program in
europe especially our booster program we
have new treatments that didn't exist
before including antibiotics and we have
a fantastic testing i'm not interrupting
you for the sake of it but we've had
this conversation before and uh viewers
have heard that um just to be clear in
your last sentence are you telling me
that you've actually had a suggestion
from sage that they should be further
locked down no the suggestion we've had
from sage is the one that they've
published it's in their minute it's
public so there's their suggestions i
think are quite clear uh there but as i
say as as government you know we are
advised by scientists but it's
ultimately that ministers uh will make a
decision and when we make a decision
there's a number of factors that we need
to take into account if as we are
hearing from scientists and from the bma
that the numbers are suggesting that
they should be further locked down will
the government be prepared to uh
undertake that but we we've shown in the
past as as government in dealing with
this pandemic that we will do what is
what is necessary but it's got to be
backed up by the data and as i say we
are very
if the data suggests that unless you act
now as some scientists are saying and
you've we already said the doubling
numbers are dramatic every day count if
the numbers suggest that we should have
further restrictions will you be ready
to do that we are watching the data
discussing it with our scientists and
our best advisors almost on an hourly
basis and and we will monitor that very
carefully we will keep the situation in
the review but i i can't stress it of
how the situation today in terms of our
defenses is very different you started
your program today by comparing it to
christmas last year one big difference
christmas last year are the vaccinations
the antivirals the other treatments our
testing systems and the fact that we
opened up in the summer in the way that
we did and if uh you did have to take
some new measures would you recall
parliament to approve those measures
look if and it's an if
the the prime minister's already been
cleared to parliamentarians if there was
a need to take any further action we
would recall parliament and it would
have to be a decision for parliament
that is only right and proper
let's talk about the politics um
lord frost went last night um
did you
know that that was going to happen and
do you understand his reasons for
leaving
i didn't know it's going to happen and i
do understand his reasons and let me
just say this first about lord frost
i've had the privilege of working with
him now for a couple of years i think
he's an outstanding public servant and i
think that you know the way brexit was
done and how we achieved that and
achieved those successes
he's been a central architect of that so
i wish him the best but i do understand
his reasons he's a principled man you
know principal people do resign from the
government i know all about that and uh
and that's something uh as a decision
for him to take but it's pretty
catastrophic isn't it uh half of your
branches voted against you during the
week uh you lost and not in uh north
shropshire uh
what is undesirable
undeniable is that uh the magic of boris
johnson has gone last time we spoke
about this um i i asked
you and i've in fact asked mr zahawi uh
last week whether um boris johnson was
still uh the election winner when we
spoke you said one word yes
are you still prepared to say yes
i think boris johnson just the one i
think i think boyce johnson is the best
person to take us through the challenge
that's not the same thing as saying he's
an electrical winner yeah what he what
he we've had
we've had one very disappointing
election result and from that you cannot
take away the ability for of boris
johnson to win election after election
remember just a couple of weeks ago we
had a by-election victory as well so
this uh don't get me wrong i think the
north structure result was a very
disappointing result we have to learn
lessons from it we especially have to
listen to the people of north shropshire
and i hope that at the next election we
can win that seat back but when you're
asking me about boris johnson remember
it is boris johnson that made the
decisions around the pandemic to to keep
britain out of the european medical
agency for example which meant that we
had the biggest and the best vaccination
program in europe to buy antivirals to
open up in the summer it's the same
boris johnson that is taking us through
this pandemic okay well here is what the
people of north shropshire said to that
same boris johnson with their vote which
is
after barnard castle after the christmas
parties after pretty much everything
else we're hearing out of whitehall
same question i asked your colleagues
more than once this year
why should we when we obey the ruled and
you flank them
why should we pay the blindest bit of
attention to what you tell us to do mr
health secretary when you say we need to
tackle omicron you know i i understand
that and uh i i absolutely understand
where those kinds of questions might
come from and that's why i think it is
really really important
that we maintain public confidence by
having that investigation that is now
taking place
by sue gray is carrying out this
investigation and that will establish
who owes her job to you shouldn't it be
led by somebody independent
well i
i i think that's not
yeah i know this isn't your intention
but i don't think that's very respectful
to to sue grey in this
she's a senior civil servant uh that
that is uh someone who is is known for
her neutrality and uh her probity and i
think
having having a senior civil servant
that is not a minister not a politician
carry out investigation that's not
unusual
that's exactly the sort of whitehall
answer that makes people feel cynical
that of course you would say that but
actually the question is shouldn't
somebody independent do this and let me
just ask you because we're running out
of time let me just ask you
what this is really uh about
in scotland they've already moved to
tougher measures
and they're doing that with confidence
because people believe in that country
in
their prime minister can you look me in
the face and say honestly that you
believe that england will be equally
compliant when asked to do tougher
things from a by a prime minister who
can't even impose discipline on his own
office
i i think i think people will uh if
first of all
you're suggesting there are new measures
to take and let's just see what happens
we as i say we keep the situation in the
review but if we do have to take uh
further measures uh as as the situation
develops if we have to do that then i
believe the british people will respond
in the same way they have throughout
this pandemic whereas they understand
the issues they know just how important
it is for them and their families and
and and they will respond accordingly
health secretary thank you very much for
your time this morning thank you
the man tasked with shadowing the health
secretary for labor is the recently
appointed west streeting so far he
supported additional covert restrictions
and the parties helped the government
get them through parliament despite
rebelling tory back benches
now with talk of more restrictions and
more rebellions the government might
need that support again
so how far will labour go where's
treating joint me now good morning mr
streeting good morning travis um
you've become secretary of state you've
heard secretary of state and on their
response uh
he doesn't seem quite yet to have
decided that there are going to be more
restrictions um are they right to wait
and see what the data will show what
were two things firstly if there's one
thing that the sage report the minutes
published yesterday tells us if there's
one thing that our experience in the
pandemic tells us is the action sooner
rather than later
means that the
strength of the restrictions and the
impact on people's lives livelihoods and
liberties
is lowered so
actions sooner rather than later would
be better rather than worse
the second thing to say is listening to
sajid javid this morning
in that interview he looked like a
hostage to his own party and that's
because he is what we saw this week in
parliament with the huge rebellion over
100 conservative mps on what were
actually quite modest
measures
tells us that the prime minister has a
big problem when it comes to the crisis
of confidence in his leadership within
his own ranks
and crucially that is impacting on the
government's public health response so
sadja javid looks like a hostage the
good news here is that the labour party
is here to rescue him from that
situation he doesn't have to negotiate
with the people holding him to ransom on
his back benches because we will act in
the public interest we will put public
health before party politics and we will
work with uh government scientists
medical advisors as we have done
throughout the pandemic to put public
health first and that should be the only
focus of the government well that that
is immensely generous of you um but the
truth is you disagree with some of the
detail but basically you
support what johnson and javed uh want
well we'll be guided by the scientific
advice we're hoping to meet with the
chief medical officer and scientific
advisors today for a briefing on where
we are to test some of their assumptions
and to think about what might be
necessary there are areas where we think
the government can and should have gone
further already actually which is not
about restrictions statutory sick pay
should be higher because there are lots
of people who are supposed to be
isolating but feel they can't afford to
do so
as a result of the very sensible advice
that chris whittie gave the country
earlier this week lots of people have
voted with their feet have made
different choices about how to spend
their social interactions whether
they're going out socializing the
hospitality industry and others have
taken a hit through no fault of their
own and and support there is needed for
the industry the government could for
example with these covered
loans that people have taken out give
people a bit of a repayment break help
get their finances in order so there are
things the government can and should be
doing which they're not so it's not just
the case that we're voting to support
measures in the public interest we are
encouraging the government to go further
to help people are feeling pain in their
pockets yeah but with respect that's
that's all the nice stuff it's always
it's everybody's in favor of giving the
public more money
will you be in favor and will you be
voting with the government if they bring
in further restrictions for example
uh
a further lockdown well i don't think
anyone wants to see a lockdown i hope we
i hope we don't have to go but if the
data tells you that that's what's needed
as scientists are beginning to say this
morning will you be ready to vote for a
further lockdown but as i say trevor i i
don't think that a lockdown would be
necessary if the government takes action
sooner rather than later so we're you
know i'm not trying to be difficult
about this we're going to see the chief
medical officer and the scientific
advice when you say follow the advice
well when you say sooner rather than
later the scientists are saying today
today this morning get on with it
and
i i don't quite understand what you're
saying are you what are you waiting for
to say let's get on with it either you
believe the scientist or you don't well
with respect the government had this
advice
on thursday in the in the form of the
sage minutes the government have access
to far more
information options advice than the
opposition do i don't think unreasonably
given that i saw the sage minutes last
night that i want to speak to the chief
medical officer and scientific advisors
so that we can come to an informed view
and i hope that will be today the
question is so we might ask you
something the question is well i think
we might hear something from labor
tomorrow the question is why is it
having received that advice on thursday
the prime minister has said nothing done
nothing well i can tell you why is
because he's hiding from his own back
benches instead of leading and that kind
of weakness in place of leadership
should really concern the public because
i think people out there know
that measures are necessary all they
want to know is what measures when and
how can i plan for them contrast across
that with and what's going on in wales
mark drakeford the first minister set
out a plan that takes wales right into
the new year i dare say people won't
necessarily like
measures who does but at least people
have some certainty they know he's doing
the right thing for the right reasons
and they can see what that path looks
like why don't we have a plan for
england you've told me you're meeting
the uh chief medical officer we hope so
we do have a cabinet
so um
let's say 48 hours so we can expect
within 48 hours for labour to take a
view about whether we need further
restrictive measures or not i hope so if
the prime minister isn't prepared to
lead we've shown that we are prepared to
lead and we're prepared to do what is
necessary in the public interest we put
public health before party politics
early this week we will continue to do
so again i think it would be preferable
by the way for the government to have a
plan
and for them to pick up the phone and
work with us in the national interest
we're prepared to do that too but the
question is how is it having known this
information on thursday
that the government have failed to say
anything do anything in fact the only
thing i be beyond the interview we heard
from the health secretary this morning
his other big intervention is uh an
op-ed in the daily telegraph today why
because he's talking to his party not
talking to the country he's negotiating
with his backbenchers he's not working
in a bipartisan way to take the action
that might be necessary to get the
country through this and that that's
what i think we should be concerned
about the prime minister's weakness is
now undermining public health well let
me ask you a question about something
that might be puzzling some viewers if
you think that the prime minister's
essentially the biggest obstacle here
why are you voting consistently to
support his measures and essentially
keep him in office wouldn't be the best
thing for a responsible patriotic
opposition that thinks that boris
johnson is not fit to lead quote your
leader who is the wrong person to be uh
guiding us through this crisis wouldn't
be the most important thing number one
priority get rid of boris johnson if
there's a motion of no confidence
tomorrow we'd be voting for that we'd be
we
why
because trevor you know as well as i do
had labor played party politics in the
way that you described with the votes
earlier this week the measures would
have fallen public health would have
been weakened and people would have
rightly said why is labour playing party
politics with public health you also
know if we take a table the most of no
confidence in the house of commons
tomorrow the conservative party mps
including those who think boris johnson
is a busted flush and an albatross
around the next they'd vote against the
motion because they'd pull together so
look there are lots of armchair critics
who say why don't labour do this why
don't labour do that the answer is
because we thought it through and we've
realized that these are futile measures
we're not going to play party politics
with public health and we are you know
what we are going to do is show the
leadership and responsible leadership
that the country would expect to see
from us and that's what we've done this
week do you think if the government
seeks
further restrictions do you think the
public is going to fall in line again
well i think the press conference
earlier this week with chris whitty
showed us that while people have lost
trust and confidence in boris johnson
they do trust as we do the chief medical
officer they do trust the chief
scientific advisor they do trust the nhs
so in the end i trust the british people
to do the right thing i think what's
reprehensible here is that boris johnson
through his own actions and the actions
of those people around him have
undermined trust and confidence in
public health messaging
from the government at a critical time
and that's why i think to be honest when
it comes to the next phase boris johnson
if he's determined to stick around like
a bad smell needs to take a step back
and push to the forefront of public
health messaging clinicians people on
the front line of the nhs because people
do trust them
and they do trust their experience and
so i think in the end the public will do
the right thing we're a law abiding
country but at the moment
people are making their own decisions
because the government isn't leading all
right there's a politics show let's
let's talk uh politics um
the uh and let's talk about the
by-election this week um to give him his
credit boris johnson took responsibility
for the tory's loss in north shropshire
when is your leader going to take
responsibility for losing nearly
9 000
votes uh in this by-election last time
around you had more than 12 000 this
time you didn't break four thousand i
don't think we're disappointed by the
result in north shropshire well you lost
three quarters of your vote and you're
not disappointed i think it's a
significant defeat for boris johnson and
what north shropshire shows us trevor
steady steady you were second in this
seat the lib dems walked straight past
you come on
i think what north shropshire shows us
trevor is that political parties are
perfectly capable of making informed
judgments about where to spend their
resources and voters can be trusted to
make the decisions that give them the
outcome that they want in this case
removing a conservative mp and i get the
slightest bit disappointed by the result
in north shropshire okay you're
obviously having a laugh here but there
is a serious point here
doesn't this demonstrate that if you are
absolutely as serious as you purport to
be about boris johnson's failings that
the labour party the liberal democrats
the greens all now have to start
thinking if they really mean what they
say that it's time to start thinking
about an alliance that would actually
put you in power because that's the only
way to get rid of this person that you
never cease to say day in day out is not
fit to lead this country
i don't think that voters like the idea
of backroom deals and tax between
political parties i think voters are
perfectly capable of making their own
informed choices about the outcome that
they want to see
so you know looking at um the the lie of
the electoral map there will be some
parts of the country where uh getting
rid of a conservative mp the route to
that the best route to that the easiest
route to that is to vote liberal
democrat there are far more places in
the country where the routes are getting
rid of a conservative mp and delivering
a labour government is by voting in
labour voters voters can make more
decisions no i don't think that i don't
think that's a choice actually
and and if boris johnson leads the
conservative party into the next general
election more for the conservative party
but that's that's for them to worry
about i think what the labour party has
shown this week in particular but since
kiersten became leader is we've got a
serious leader with a serious team
capable of governing the country we know
we've got more work to do to win back
trust don't want to give your viewers
the impression we're in any way
complacent about this but we're
determined to do that work we're
determined to win the trust and
confidence of the people we can do that
without backroom deals and we'll put our
best foot forward and let the people
decide we're streeting thank you very
much indeed
if it's been a bad week for the
government but a good week for the
liberal democrats it usually means
there's been a by-election
well that was certainly the case in
north shropshire somewhere that's been
true blue for 200 years until the lib
dems overturned a vast majority to take
the seat that used to be held by owen
patterson
libnam leader ed davey tweeted a video
of himself celebrating with a fist pump
when that result became clear now he
joins me again
um
sorry there you are
ed davey um you must be very cheerful
this morning congratulations is this the
um
start of the lib dem uh resurgence or is
it just the usual mid-term protest vote
that will disappear in the general
election
well cleveland isn't very excited by our
victory it's the second by-election
victory for the liberal democrats
against the conservatives this year
that's not happened since 1993
so i'm really proud of our party i'm
really proud of our campaigners and i
think we've brought hope to the whole
nation we've proven that conservatives
can be beaten anywhere and i think we
can confirm the reality that if we're
going to get johnson the tories out of
office it's going to take the liberal
democrats beating conservative mps in
their blue wool seats
well when you say you can beat the
conservatives anywhere um
let's just
talk a bit about the nature of your
campaign in north shropshire um we had a
look at your election leaf ritz leaflet
sleaze was referenced 13 times christmas
party scandal mentioned just once
healthcare is what you focused on with
140 mentions in the leaflets including
72 mentions of the ambulance uh uh the
station being moved from aussie street
to uh shrewsbury farming uh mentioned 41
times essentially
you didn't really talk to the voters of
north shropshire about boris johnson at
all you focused on some local issues are
you going to do that everywhere and
expect to beat the conservatives
focused on the issues that the voters
were concerned about it's the
westminster bubble who thinks it's all
about uh partygate and peppa pig and so
on we know different and the voters are
not shropshiring you differently
you did
no they raised it to us um i went on the
doorstep trevor i went to north
shropshire five times like i campaigned
for 10 days and in the early days way
before partygate what people were saying
they were worried about delays to
ambulance services i heard really sad
stories about people waiting in pain for
8 10 12 hours and we responded to that
so we looked at what the concerns have
been doing on ambulance services and
they'd failed the people of north
shropshire the west midlands ambulance
services is in crisis and the concerns
have done nothing about it they've taken
the people of north shropshire as in so
many parts of the country totally for
granted so i make no apology for the
liberal democrats campaigning on health
issues on farming issues they were the
issues that were really important to the
people of north shropshire we will be a
community politics campaigning party not
just in north shropshire and cheshire
with our amazing by-election victories
this year but across the country there
will be many conservative mps now who
are really worried the liberal democrats
now are putting on a performance in
different parts of the country that is
the sort of things that saw the
conservatives thrown out of government
in 1997 for 13 years so you know i do
have a smile on my face i do think
there's new hope for our country and i
do think the conservatives are in real
trouble
but when you say davey that you can beat
the conservatives everywhere you're now
saying you'll do that entirely largely
on the basis of what's happening locally
doesn't that open you to the traditional
criticism of liberal democrats that you
will say one thing in one constituency
and say pretty much the opposite next
door if that's what suits you locally
well that criticism has never been true
and it's not true now we're campaigning
on the health service inconsistencies
around the country it's a national issue
and we're not
campaigning on farming issues in urban
areas because there are no farms trevor
we campaign our farming issues in
farming areas where there are farmers
who want to know about our policies on
that uh our politics and farming are
still available to others of course um
so i think i think this argument that
sometimes pharmacy you tell the farmers
in north shropshire that a lib dem
government would spend more money on
farming and you're telling uh the voters
in uh london urban constituencies that
you'll spend the money on something
different wouldn't you
well not at all we always put forward a
cost of manifesto which you publish for
the whole country and actually i think
my constituents are worried about what's
happening to britain's agriculture
actually because the tories are breaking
their promises they said they would put
put in place a system to support our
farmers but actually taking that away
before the new system is coming place
that's another broken promise just like
the conservatives have broken promises
on the triple lock-on pensions for
example on on leveling up and i think
there's a story about the conservatives
they are letting people down they said
all these things boris johnson settles
these things and and he's not delivering
they have taken people for granted that
is why the liberal democrats won in
north shropshire why be db1 in cheshire
and amisham and why i'm i'm so excited
about the prospects ahead of us now i
think there's a real chance of getting
boris johnson and the conservatives out
of power the next election and i think
the liberal democrats have shown the way
well let me put the same question to you
that i put to west streeting
surely the best chance of getting rid of
boris johnson and
his party from government would be if
there were some cooperation between the
parties who all seem to think think the
same thing about him and his
administration why aren't you ready for
an alliance with other parties on the
center and on the left
trevor let me first say that i'm really
grateful to traditional labour voters
lifelong labour voters who in north
shropshire indeed cheshire amisham lent
liberal democrats their votes so we
could beat the conservatives it worked
but the issue really is allowing voters
to have those choices these choices are
organic in many ways you don't need a
form or even an informal pact or deal
voters can work out which is the
candidate best place to beat the
conservative mp during our first past
the post system and it shouldn't be
surprising anybody that opposition party
leaders want to see the conservatives
beaten and they're going to put our
resources
where we think we are the best uh
vehicle for uh beating the conservatives
we will make our positive case
absolutely um but i think people from
other parties who know
where the liberal democrats are the
challenges they will come and back us
that's what that's what happened in
north rupture
uh davey uh well it looks like you're
gonna have a happy christmas thank you
very much for your time this morning
thank you
well let's focus on covid again and
those sharply rising cases and
increasing hospitalizations especially
in london that mean that the government
is once again wrestling with the
introduction of yet more restrictions on
our daily lives i can speak now to sir
mark walport who was the chief
scientific advisor to the uk government
between 2013 and 2017. he's now the
chief executive of uk research and
innovation good morning sir mark
good morning
does the um
scientific data that you've seen
suggest
that we need further restrictions and
further restrictions now
well i i mean in a word yes um we have
we're at risk and difficult moment
infections are rising fast uh we're
identifying more than 90 000 cases a day
now but that will translate actually
into hundreds of thousands of new cases
a day
um and in london which is the worst
affected at the moment and incidentally
is also well not incidentally is also
the least well vaccinated part of the
country um hospital admissions are
rising significantly so
we need to act to hold down the rate of
hospital admissions
um reduce the pressure on the workforce
and of course a lot of people are off
sick at the moment and most importantly
of all give people the chance to get
vaccinated to get boosted and allow time
for those
vaccinations to have effect
um
that in a moment but before we do that
aside from the blue stone vaccination
what would you say are the most
effective steps uh policy steps that
could be taken
now
uh to slow the spread of omicron
the effective steps are the steps that
we can all take which have been the
steps all along which is that this is a
virus that transmits by uh moving from
one person to another particularly
through
aerosol and droplet spread so
respiratory spread and so uh distancing
people one from another is by far and
away the most effective way of stopping
that spread but also wearing close
fitted masks
and
you know it's clear that people's
behavior is becoming more cautious
and that makes common sense so it is
about as i say well fitting masks
avoiding crowded indoor poorly
ventilated spaces lots of people
reducing contacts and making sure that
we test a lot so we've got tests
and we should use the results if we have
symptoms we should isolate
um these are all measures that we can
take um and plan b
you know is obviously heading in that
direction but the modeling projection
suggests that it won't be sufficient on
its own to
flatten the peak and reduce the pressure
on the health system
and on people being off work
do you support would you support chris
woody's advice
reduce the number of households that mix
try and avoid
essentially social contact social mixing
if you can over the next period
yes i mean what chris whittake said and
you know he is the nation's public
health doctor um and he's giving uh
excellent public health advice is that
you know reduce your contacts to those
that really matter to you so you know
the less the better but i mean this is
the second christmas that has the
potential to be significantly ruined for
a number of people
and so you know there are also the
health issues of not being able to see
your loved ones but so you know the
answer is to
uh be prudent um and
you know only have the social contacts
which are really important to you
you've had the task of trying to
evaluate uh significant
level uh amounts of scientific uh data
for government and advised ministers and
so on that is proving crucial right now
um
there is a major issue about the
modeling uh that is be that is emerging
from various sources um
i put to the health sector this morning
what uh the chair of the modeling
committee of sage said which is that we
are generally asked to model uh we are
generally modeling what we are asked to
model
in a sense what he's saying is that
there is uh
the evidence that is being produced uh
is that which the politicians are asking
in order to support further restrictions
uh does that make sense to you that
actually what's happening here
it doesn't make any sense at all
actually um i mean the model is i mean
the first thing to do is say that the
modelers produce projections they don't
produce predictions
and all of the models have wide
uncertainties attached to them as well
and this has been no different
throughout this pandemic at all i mean
what the modelers are being asked to do
um is to
model what happens under various
conditions of you know free mixing less
mixing
to provide
the policy makers with the best possible
evidence they can have
there's no suggestion that you know the
evidence is there to support policy the
evidence is there to help policy makers
decide
and that's always been the case
and you know one of the big challenges
for everyone is that there is inevitably
a great deal of uncertainty particularly
during the early phases of a wave of you
know any pandemic infection and
particularly uh now where we've got the
omicron variant it's new we still don't
know a lot about it
um so you know frankly the evidence is
not there that it is either less severe
or more severe than the delta variant we
just don't know but what we do know is
that the cases are rising very fast i
mean anyone who just looks at the
numbers of cases can see that
you can just look at the graph which is
widely available and you can see that
the numbers are going up extremely
rapidly
um
and uh
so that's that's what the modeling is
all about
so
but you do you do see what why this is
becoming a political issue that the
critics of the government are
essentially saying
that the evidence that is being demanded
is uh only evidence
that will support the their the
government's desire to impose greater
restrictions and when models are being
different scenarios are being offered as
model as uh scientists always do
you rightly say they're not predictions
they are different possibilities but the
the possibility on which ministers are
acting are the worst scenarios uh is
that but
with respect a criticism that
that you can see the sense of
no i the last thing any government wants
to do is to increase the restrictions i
mean
that that's there's no political
pressure of any sort as it were to
increase the restrictions uh it's all
about actually responding to the
evidence from a pandemic where the
number of cases are rising fast we have
a new variant we have pressure on the
health service with increased hospital
admissions
and
the risks are that because of the lag
and that's always the challenge that
people you know forget each time that
from the moment you get an infection
become symptomatic to when you may have
to go into hospital is a week to 10 days
or so and then it's another you know two
or three weeks before
the worst effects of the infection
particularly death may occur
and so you know if you're going to act
you actually have to act in advance and
that's one of the difficult things but
you know the job of the scientists is to
actually provide the evidence for the
policy makers the policy makers our
politicians and therefore ultimately the
decisions are political decisions but
there's no pressure on sage or sage
advisors or the modelers to do anything
other than to provide the best possible
evidence you know given that there are
uncertainties at any moment
so mark thank you so much for your time
this morning much appreciated
making sense of the flurry of numbers
we're bombarded with about covid can
seem nigh on impossible cases are
soaring but how's that going to
translate into hospitalizations and
deaths and how will the severity of the
new variant influence the level of new
restrictions
well let's try to work through some of
that now with professor sir david
spiegelhalter who is a leading
statistician possibly the leading
statistician based at the university of
cambridge and the author of covid
by numbers good morning uh sir david
good morning
now we're hearing about
a large number uh range of possible
scenarios for the spread and impact of
omicron um it's pretty confusing i think
for most people and it ranges from
a widespread but relatively mild in
disease to a devastating
um wave that could overwhelm the nhs can
you just start by uh with the numbers
roughly how many cases do you think we
have right now
okay the first thing is to distinguish
between people who are getting infected
and people who then become cases
because the data we see every day are
just the people who got got ill they've
got symptoms they've gone along got a
pcr test they've gone on to the system
and they've been recorded as a positive
case and those are running and you know
yesterday they went down a bit to 90 000
but we shouldn't take too much
notice of those exact numbers and it
depends so much on who on whether people
get symptoms whether they decide to get
tested
and labs are going to get very stretched
and so um
they actually only give a very crude
idea of what the infection rate was
i'm sorry
about four days before and i think
there's no doubt that um you know we are
getting hundreds of thousands of
infections every day now and the
majority of them will be omicron and i
think there's no doubt about that at all
well the consequences of that is is a
bit more tricky but one thing we can be
absolutely sure
now about the consequences are purely of
becoming a case
you know because then you're supposed to
isolate for 10 days and um and that's
going to cause is causing already and
will cause even more massive disruption
and that's nothing to do with whether
how ill people get in hospitalizations
we just know that there's going to be
huge disruption over over you know next
weeks and months
do you think um well first of all let's
do a bit of range finding um do you do
you think that uh the likely rate of
hospitalizations
given all that is going to be
greater or
less fewer lesser than with last year's
delta wave
oh it could be could be greater could be
lesser no i know this sounds like i'm
completely sitting on the fence and
that's because i'm sitting on the fence
because all the modelling says we don't
know and the the suggestion is uh you
had this discussion just now with mark
walput about the range of scenarios that
are explored well one of those scenarios
that has been modeled is just to stick
with plan b and not to bring in any new
interventions at all and the models then
suggest that hospitalization would go uh
you know pretty confident they're going
to go above 3 000 a day well that's
still less than it was last winter so um
even if we don't do anything more and
you know they could be better than last
winter um but and if we did do things uh
you know bring in other other sort of
restrictions then that could be reduced
but enormous uncertainty about those
numbers there's so much we don't know
one of them we are finding out
information now from london where
hospitalizations are going up and one of
the very interesting things is that um
if you look at the uh the new cases the
new hospitalizations over and above what
they have been over the last few months
um around about half of those are
actually people who admitted with
something else and then were found to
have covered probably the omicron
variant and so
that suggests that if you've got a
population where a huge number getting
infected then they'll go that might go
to hospital something else but then they
found have covered and so they have to
be treated you know as they've got
covered which of course is a huge drain
on resources so um
just having a high level of infection
itself
causes this huge um
uh
you know stress on resources even if
people are not getting that ill
so
you're thinking that even if as people
keep saying
the south african data and i'd be
interested in your view about that uh is
suggesting that it might be minor even
with that we could still face not just
because of the numbers uh but because of
the phenomena you've just described an
overwhelming pressure on the nhs
could do and it could be um you know it
could be manageable even with sticking
with the with the um um the uh situation
at the moment i mean it it very much
depends
on
you know
there is so much uncertainty and so what
does one do in terms of the action and
i'm certainly not going to suggest any
policy whatsoever um is that um you know
just how cautious does one want to be
but as mark walput said one of the
crucial things is you can't wait to find
out we can't wait for hospitalizations
to go through the roof before we do
something about it because by then it's
too late and in fact what happens by the
end of the new year by the end of this
year is pretty well built in now there's
almost pretty well nothing we can do
about it boosters won't have a big
effect on it and we're going to be
running hospitalizations will be up it's
estimated between a thousand and two
thousand a day and that is going to
happen whatever we do so the first thing
is you know when we go further into the
new year um
what's what's that peak going to be can
we delay it can we flatten it and um we
will know more you know we're learning
more every day
but in the same case every day we delay
we'll have a bigger impact further on
now i'm glad i'm not having to make
those decisions um because they are
extremely difficult ones because well
indeed
forgive me
you say that every day makes a
difference uh everybody now i think is
beginning to understand what the word
exponential means doubling and so on
doubling every day and so on
if you had a free hand what signal would
you be looking for to see that we needed
to take
stricter
more severe measures greater
restrictions what what what signal in
the data would you be looking for
oh i think looking at what everyone else
looks at i mean we would love to know
exactly how many people are being
infected and and
we will find that out but a bit with
rather a delay when we do a proper
infection survey which is going on all
the time but it means there's about a
week's delay before we hear about what
the results are and we have to just work
with the data we've got because we don't
see when the virus is transmitted and we
don't see exactly how you know why
people get particularly ill or whatever
we have to infer it and that's what
stats is about i suppose trying to work
out what's going on from the little
bits of information that we actually
find which are deeply imperfect and that
that i think is is inevitable and
yeah i i think
one of the things the other thing is to
actually look outside this country and
see what's happening
for example in europe holland's just
locked down over christmas with
something that our government is first
extremely reluctant to bring in measures
before christmas um but uh it's going to
be you know austria and germany for
example have just managed to control
their huge delta peak it's come down
their death rates are still you know at
least double what they are in the uk
and then omicron's going to hit them uh
it's going to be very very tough for
these countries and and uh you know
we're not in a great situation but
actually with our vaccine rollout our
coverage of boosters is extremely good
you know it should have been better we
should have done a huge amount more
during the autumn i think but um it's
getting better all the time and so we're
actually comparatively in uh somewhat
better situation than many many other
countries the other thing is that sorry
sorry uh uh professor spiegelhalter uh i
think we've run out of time
unfortunately but uh thank you very much
uh for joining us this morning
thank you
well it's been by anyone's calculations
a pretty bad few weeks for the
conservative party uh number ten's uh
reputation and is in tatters labor's
gained a consistent poll lead
rumblings about the prime minister's
future there have been big back bench
rebellions and another crushing
by-election defeat and now of course the
shock resignation by brexit minister
lord frost
so just how are the backbenchers feeling
about things and are they limbering up
for another big fight with the
leadership over covered restrictions
let's ask one of those that's those said
backbenches who is no stranger to
rebellion peter bone mp
good morning sir peter
well good morning and thank you for a
merry christmas to you and uh thank you
to for knighting me i'm i'm definitely
not a knight and uh not likely to be but
yeah it's a difficult time we have to
battle with
all these um
all these
deeply imperfect uh statistics
forgive me oh so there's there's still a
possibility that they could keep you
quiet somehow isn't there um anyway i
think that's very unlikely
let's let's deal with um let's deal with
the uh resignation of lord frost um he
cites concerns about the government's
current direction of travel hopes for
lighter regulations lower tax and a more
entrepreneurial
economy do you share those uh concerns
and if you do
is it just you or how many of your back
bench colleagues would uh say the same
thing
oh i think absolutely what lord frost
says is what i'm looking
towards boris doing in the future and i
think so many of my colleagues are i
mean boris has
led this country
exceptionally well um you know getting
brexit down um
dealing with kobe keeping our spirits up
and getting
the
the vaccination first in the world
saving millions of lives and keeping
people in jobs and the economy
recovering but what comes next
and that's that's what i think lord
frost was talking about and and i think
part of that um
rebellion of a hundred conservative mps
was partly due to the fact that we want
to see
the prime minister move to a more
conservative agenda
in the future
yeah but lord frost seems to think he's
moving in exactly the opposite direction
here's what he says in this letter you
took a brave decision in july
against considerable opposition to open
up the country again sadly it did not
prove to be irreversible as i wished and
believe you you did too he's basically
saying that uh boris johnson uh was
was
right in july but he's somehow gone soft
is that your your view too
well i think the argument obviously i
voted against um having
vaccine passports and therefore i i do
think the prime minister was wrong on
that and i'm i'm much more for keeping
society open and people using common
sense i mean
i've cancelled all um in-person meetings
and the the get get together with staff
i've cancelled and i won't be going to
crowded places but leave that up to the
individual to make that decision don't
have the state telling me what i have to
do every day and so in that regard yes
i'm with law frost on that and i think
that's
i i i i it's a job of back benches to to
to speak that to speak that uh that
message to the prime minister so he he
can take it into account when making
decisions and it really is time for us
to
um
people say you have to live with kobe we
do have to live with go we have to get
boosted and we have to use common sense
but i don't want to have to show up
passport to get into to a football match
for instance
well mr mr mr bone you say it's all
about covered but are you sure we aren't
still fighting yesterday's battle um
there's a whatsapp group which um i
think you are of which i think you are a
member and my uh sky news colleague um
uh sam coats uh i i think uh obtained
this in which one of your colleagues
marcus fish says uh the whole point of
brexit is radical supply-side reform
moving away from the eu model yet
ministers are happy to give hard-won
power in their hands to achieve this to
officials who will do the opposite are
you sure you aren't still fighting
2016 and 19.
i wouldn't believe everything you read
from a leaked whatsapp group i mean i
look at that are you saying that isn't
true
sorry
are you saying that uh marcus fish did
not write that oh i don't know because
i'm i'm sorry i have no knowledge of
that but what i'm saying is uh
i wouldn't rule the country from
watching a whatsapp group i think
people have got to make up the minds
what they want in the future i want a a
society that can move forward
more open and not more restricted and i
i absolutely agree that we've got great
advantages of coming out of the european
union and one of the things was we
wouldn't have had the vaccination
program so early if we'd been stuck in
europe in the european medical agency so
there are huge advantages and we must
take those advantages and move forward
kovid i'm afraid has blown
not unreasonably the government of
course because it's such a major crisis
and i i mean i think parliament should
be back next week
discussing i don't think parliament
should be suspended well while there's a
national crisis going on i don't eat
mince pies and drink tea when there's a
crisis i want to be in westminster
scrutinizing the government
and and helping it make the right
decisions
not not uh eating mince pies with your
colleagues i i'm pretty sure given the
the rules but look you know
you said that we don't rule things by
whatsapp group but the uh
communications between members of
parliament do tell us something about
the morale and the spirit uh within a
political party and here's a striking
thing which you might want to comment on
it appears that um this same whatsapp
group
of
uh
conservative members of parliament one
of the members was
nadine dory's mp who is now the
secretary of state for culture and uh
in the discussion on this whatsapp group
which was basically expressing
dissatisfaction with boris johnson she
entered the discussion to defend boris
johnson and was booted off the group now
you can say that you know all the
high-minded things about freedom and all
the rest of it but doesn't this really
speak of a party that is
pretty much tearing itself apart
well
that's definitely not true the last bit
um i think there's a great deal of
support for the prime minister i'm a
great fan of um
boris i i led the back boris campaign
along with tom purse club and helen
harrison i mean we're we're right behind
the front we just want to say come on
let's get on to a conservative agenda
and i think the thing on the whatsapp
group i might be wrong because i'm but i
don't think
ministers are supposed to be on that
particular whatsapp group and maybe
that's why and nadine was removed um
but i you know i'll be honest i don't
know it happens about what's happening
i'm really okay look
the other the underlying point is here
that uh you are expressing
an admirable degree of loyalty to the
prime minister this morning but the
truth is a large
number of your colleagues
who knows maybe half of the back benches
have first of all more or less fallen
out of love with the prime minister and
more importantly possibly do no no
longer think of him as the winner that
they backed in 2019
uh
do you still think that boris johnson
is an asset to the party that it cannot
do without
well first of all let's make i
absolutely think he's an asset to the
party i disagree fundamentally with your
analysis that there are huge numbers of
conservative mps that are against the
prime minister i think what's being
mixed up is the rebellion over vaccine
passports which people felt in principle
were completely wrong
and and the desire to get rid of the
prime minister look if if
i wouldn't be defending the prime
minister if i didn't think he was doing
a good job i was quite happy to stand up
in the house of commons and call for
theresa may to go
in the middle of the the brexit
brexit crisis so no i absolutely think
that's right i think the media
if
if they bring in if they are if they ask
you to agree to vaccine passports what's
the number that's going to that uh will
rebel
sorry did you say vaccine parcels well
we've always voted for that correct more
restrictions let's just more
restrictions more restrictions so look
say that the government came along and
said we need to go into full lockdown
and i would well that they have to do is
come to parliament make their case make
the arguments explain
but how many are going to rebel well no
you can't that's you can't answer that
question until you know what the
situation is and that's the point come
to parliament make your case be
scrutinized debate it and then we'll
decide and if necessary if i think
they're right i'll vote for it if i
don't think all right against it
mr bone thank you very much indeed this
morning
england's chief medical officer
professor chris witte created headlines
and no shortage of anger this week when
he told people to prioritize and limit
social contact ahead of christmas since
then pubs restaurants theaters and high
streets have been eerily quieter than
they would normally be at this time of
year
it's had a huge impact on business
especially entertainment travel and
hospitality
few people know their way around the
restaurant better than the world famous
chef michelle roo and i
to my great pleasure can speak to him
now
good morning mr roo
good morning trevor you can call me chef
good morning absolutely
you absolutely on money good morning
chef um
look your family's been running
restaurants for uh generations um
how bad is it now
it's really dreadful it's terrible and i
mean on a very serious note this is as
bad as um march in 2020 the first
lockdown
the biggest issue for me is the lack of
communication from the government uh
there are no
um
well we're being told one thing uh
the public has been told one thing so
don't go out don't don't you know don't
go to christmas parties
and don't congregate in numbers
um which in turn means that people
aren't going out or cancelling christmas
parties cancelling events um and and
being very careful now it could be quite
rightly so because of this pandemic
which which is awful and it is real um
but it means that
what should be our most prosperous month
as restaurateurs and as hoteliers and
republicans um is now turning into a
loss because people are not turning up
so
i'm all right with locking down don't
get me wrong locking down is a good
thing if it's going to save lives and it
means that the nhs is not going to be
unput under pressure i mean lord knows
that the nhs is doing
an unbelievable job you know fantastic
job and and you know praise to them and
of course let's not forget all the
volunteers because also the rollout of
the um of the booster and of the jabs in
the first time round uh it's not thanks
to the government it's thanks to the nhs
and thanks to the volunteers so what we
need in our industry and not just our
industry is clear government proper
proper government with a pair of
cojones that takes decisions on time not
waffle
what would you like to hear
from the prime minister over the next
couple of weeks
clear decisions it it really is simple
as that um uh trevor i mean
we we don't know whether we're coming or
going in our industry we are losing uh
business we are losing livelihoods um i
have and
also very very important point because
we're talking about hospitality industry
here which which employs you know to
2.5 3 million people directly and
what about the ecosystem around the
hospitality industry so
all the drivers that come and deliver
our goods all the security the cleaners
the
the collection of refuse the suppliers
the supply chain is immense i've i've
had supplies on the phone in tears
asking me to take some produce but i
can't take produce i've had a collapse
of bookings
and i don't know whether i'm going to be
open tomorrow let alone next week so you
know we need clear decisions and if we
get locked down um then
we need compensation we need financial
help and again i reiterate not just the
hospitality industry but across the
board
we need proper firm government and a
government that we can respect
give us a picture of what this level of
uncertainty means in your business for
you know one of your um one of your
restaurants or one of your family's
restaurants
yes i mean i i tweeted uh recently last
week about my um daughter's restaurant
and this is a you know a new business a
new restaurant with with a big debt uh
and that's another thing a lot of
restaurants you know uh small businesses
uh are already laden with debt and we're
getting help yeah we have to take a loan
out and that's another debt that's
adding debt on debt
so that i don't consider that help
financially but anyway that's another
story so
she she was um
building up to a prosperous december a
december that would see her through the
lean months of dry january uh and
february and march
they're normally quiet months
so
in this industry we need to build up
reserves in november and december to see
us through well that's gone that's
finished not nothing left so we're now
she is now into a lost situation
business-wise uh in december
the chancellor's just come back from
california industry leaders are saying
that some businesses are going to go out
go going to sink they're going to go
under
what what practical help
would work for you what would you like
to hear rishi sunak announce
once he's done his sums
um well well first of all we need
assurance going forward so next year the
v80 is likely to go back up to 20 well
um
it would help immensely if it was either
kept at 12 and a half or taken back down
to five and business rates need sorting
out that it's the most unfair system
ever um and then
statutory sick pay is one that i would
like to see reformed as well because at
the moment um people who are catching
covid
with very mild symptoms um are thinking
well shall i go to work or shall i you
know
shall i just take statutory sick pay you
can't survive on that you can't pay the
rent you can't
there's no way so some and then the
burden is put on back on the employer
that's not right so you know
there are a number of number of things
but if we are going to go into lockdown
and as i said i'm not against lockdown
i'm really not if it's for the right
reason but we need to know uh we can't
have this dilly dallying around and this
waffle that's coming out of the
government at the moment
um
you are of course uh proudly british
british michelle roo we claim you 100
as our own but of course you have some
french heritage um
what do you think about the french
decision to essentially ban travel
between here and there
what it's a firm decision
uh i mean the one the one thing whether
you you you know you like or dislike mac
hall he takes decisions uh and now
that's another thing i think there's a
lot of politicking going on between
macro and uh and boris johnson um
yeah well one thinking he's uh napoleon
bonaparte and the other one thinking
he's winston churchill uh come on guys
get out get out of the playground and
and behave properly but
you know at least uh decisions are made
and they are made quickly and with
direction it was the same with the
lockdown back in uh 2020 uh macron took
this decision to
close the restaurants uh early uh or
close down the whole country early and
to police it properly firmly uh and to
put uh you know a proper package to help
the hospitality industry um
and that you know i think that's all we
want and it's not just the hospitality
industry it's what everybody wants it's
clear decision making
um it is a politics program so i i i'm
tempted to ask you about goose versus
turkey also but i i have to ask you a
proper question uh it looks like there
might be
another lock down
do you think that
the industry can survive another one
um if there's adequate compensation then
um
yes there will still be some casualties
um and another thing which i've not
spoken about is is mental health it is
it really is
incredibly tough um i mean
two days ago i had team members staff
members at my restaurant asking me are
we shutting are we not shutting um
and and
the consequences of that uh and uh tears
in their eyes welling up i mean really
not knowing whether they've got a job or
not and we're trying to entice people
back into the hospitality industry so
you know how do how is this going to
work it is incredibly difficult times um
so
it's not just you know not just one
thing it's very very difficult but but
we need as i said before and i keep on
saying it is a strong government that
that will take decisions and and give us
proper proper help
michelle been a pleasure talking to you
thank you so much
thank you
there are of course just six days until
christmas and whether you are a person
of faith or not a time for spending time
with family and friends
for the second year in a row that will
not be possible for many of us and this
time of year is once again filled with
uncertainty as michelle has just been
saying
concern for many and hardship so with
fewer of us turning to the established
church than we used to
what does it have to offer a united
kingdom struggling with the impact of
covid
live to thanet where i can speak to the
bishop of dover rose hudson wilkin
good morning bishop thank you
for joining us i know it's uh it's a
it's one of the busiest working days of
the year for you
good morning and i i'm insanity because
i'm just about ready to do a
confirmation service
well look um
what impact is covered having
on worship and worshipers this year
the the the church has also borne the
brunt of
the impact of covid
in terms of you know we had the church
locked and then
uh people have started coming back but
there is social distancing and some
people are still shielding
and it is impacted on the church
financially in the same way that it has
uh um impacted on business and and
ordinary people's lives
but you know we are god's church this
belongs to god
and so we are there to be a sign of hope
a sign of hope
for the community and the world around
us
is that sign of hope going to be open to
worshippers through christmas and new
year
i believe that we will be open uh
through christmas and going into the new
year you know we have learned what to do
and how to manage in this pandemic town
we've learned how to um make sure that
we keep safe within our church is
something that we didn't know
initially but we do know that now and we
will continue to make sure that we are
safe once we're in our buildings
if the government were to say we're not
going to legislate but we really would
prefer people not to gather
what advice will you give to the priests
in your diocese
about for example
uh uh
christmas morning or christmas eve uh
services uh christmas morning
and indeed uh what in the old days we
used to call watch night services at the
end of the year
you know because as i said we now know
how to keep ourselves safe in terms of
washing you know we're going to have to
live with coronavirus
um it's not going to disappear and so we
can't just lock ourselves away but what
we can do
is that we can stay safe we wear our
mask we clean our hands regularly uh we
keep social distances we don't uh gather
unless we have to so i would want
the clergy in my diocese
to make the kind of decisions that says
we are keeping you safe when you come
through these doors i trust my clergy
and i am sure they will make the right
decision
you um
this is a politics show so of course
i've got to ask you something on that of
course not partisan you've probably seen
more of politics than
any uh cleric of any denomination having
been chaplain to the house of commons um
getting us through the pandemic does
depend on the authority of our leaders
um
do you have any fear that the scandals
and the revelations of the past year
have damaged uh the if you like the
moral authority of politicians
i think without a doubt we have to say
that the mixed messages
and the do what i say and not as i do
will undoubtedly have
an impact
on
on the nation going forward in terms of
how we respond
and so i would want to encourage our
politicians our political leaders
to actually
ensure
that the messages that they're giving to
the wider community is a clear message
and also
that they follow the message themself
and and you know that they say this is
for all of us and not just for you and
and not ourselves we do our own thing
in a way you're echoing uh the arts
ritual canterbury's um message the other
day which is
an appeal for honesty
in politics
yes well you know it's not just honestly
in politics it's honestly in our lives
the need for us to live
lives that
is credible um for all to see
um so you know let's not it's let's not
beat beat the politicians alone
um it's for all of us
uh to adhere to
um
bishop uh i i wouldn't do anything so
vulgarous to ask you to summarize uh
your upcoming sermon and and of course
some of our i would love to [ __ ]
some of our viewers won't share our
faith but in 30 seconds or so um it's
been a tough year
what is the shepherd's message to the
flock
i think the the main message that i want
to share
is that
god loved for god so loved the world and
it is from that love
that god gave
so what we have is this generous god who
gives off himself to the world in his
son jesus christ who came to dwell with
us so that's my message let's practice
thank you
thank you bishop
that that is as much as we have time for
this program and indeed for this year
we'll be back in the new year but till
then
um i guess the goose is getting fat but
maybe
a bit nervous about whether they're
going to be needed or not
enjoy your holiday
[Music]
you